hey this is funny um this is just a very
this is a light thing okay this is not
serious we've done a lot of serious
stuff today um
i posted a funny youtube comment
to my instagram the other day one of our
callers called in
and read it and it is even more
incoherent when you hear it
read it's almost like an audience hatred
mail take a listen to this
hi david you are a sweet you are
a fake news just like donald trump
said you don't bring the news you bring
whining right complaining things to
complain because
if you're not understanding this you are
not having a medical event right
now it really doesn't make any sense
i don't do what you want him
good want him to do it right now buying
is doing what you want him to do
so you're happy and criticizing those
people who are not sure
that this is what needs to be done right
[Laughter]
trust me i looked at it several times
before posting it to my instagram
and it still somehow made more sense
then
than it does now actually hearing it
read out so that
that is really something else i love
that we have a great bonus show for you
today
uh we are going to be previewing our
coverage
of the second impeachment trial of
donald trump which starts tomorrow i
don't even know
what time yet i've been so busy today
i'm guessing
10 a.m maybe eastern i don't know i'm
just guessing but in any case
we'll figure out what time it starts and
we are going to have
very very powerful coverage for you and
much more on today's bonus show
remember that to get instant access to
the bonus show
you need only sign up at joinpacman.com
very easy there is a coupon code the
coupon code
saves you a lot and the coupon code is
better21 it could be
all caps a lowercase
a mix of the two it is not case
sensitive
but it must be spelled correctly that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-21
no spaces whatsoever i would love to see
you
on today's bonus show otherwise i will
see you tomorrow
new show and of course of course of
course
impeachment coverage live on youtube
twitch and facebook um and then after
tomorrow we will be on vacation for
three months
so i will see everybody then that's a
joke by the way
people get mad when we go on vacation we
really don't take that much vacation
but we're here all week all right i'll
see everybody tomorrow or hopefully on
the bonus show